you know what um I realized too recently
because I just Revisited a
I Revisited Idlewild for like the first
time it feels like in like 10 years wow
because I'm a huge Outcast fan I got
equipment right there yeah but that's
like the last real I guess body of work
we got from both of them and you're on
that body of work I am it's got to be a
big like do you ever like think like
damn I'm on the last Outcast album like
that everyone exists it's legendary
um they're legendary and just as people
I love them you know they they've always
been sort of like mentors to me big boy
did a lot for my career for sure you
know and and I always thank them and
then even artistically when you look at
outcasts you know they always uh pushed
something new you know you got the the
roots of funk and and what they the way
that they did it was super Innovative
and it definitely inspired me to to to
to to start wanting to when I first
started out to be comfortable and
confident uh in being unique I was going
to say uh they did such a good job of
Reinventing them ourselves every album
and you've done a good job of kind of
Reinventing yourself every time you put
a new body of work out is that something
that because I think fans sometimes get
wrapped up in like liking their favorite
artists for like just this but I feel
like the greats like we think of
Kendrick yourself obviously Cass like
they always are Reinventing themselves
like every project like you know for you
is that something like do you always
want to make sure when you're putting
out a new body of work or you start
recording that you maybe experiment a
little bit more yeah yeah it's fun I
love the Journey of in evolving and
finding out new things about myself
discovering new things about what I can
do redefining that for myself on my turn
my own turn right
um I mean you know as artists you make
the rules so everything you know from me
today I literally made up those rules
that this is this is what I want to do
and you know this is how I'm living my
life at this time and it's always
beautiful to be able to honor where you
are at that time you can look back on
every album and like wow thank you
remember where I was where you were yeah
yeah yeah
um talk about because obviously I think
a lot of people don't realize that like
you have like an incredibly sick label
and like a guy like jidenna started with
you yes and I think Jordan is somebody
who is a [__] beast of an artist I
agree he doesn't get enough credit I
agree I kind of feel like classic man
was like a gift in a curse because it
was such a big record but yeah you gotta
dive into your dentist catalog
super talented and he actually just
released a new album yeah he did he did
um I was going to say like for you what
is your
um
when it comes to the label side and your
creative company what approach do you
take when it comes to finding Talent or
just working with somebody well right
now you know my career has taken off in
the time that I I'll just have to be
completely honest being an artist and
sort of having a label and then yes it's
a lot but even even you know even with
your dinner we're family you know like I
always I'm always like more so of a big
sister to him if he needs advice or if
he wants me to listen to a mix or if
he's like should this go on the album or
what do you think about this we talk and
and and business-wise if he needs advice
I'm there for him but for the most part
I like the artists should like be in
control of what it is that they're doing
I don't ever want to talk over that get
in the way of that
um and also be honest about just what I
can take on you know I think everything
is partnership level I think right now
you don't even need a label nobody needs
a list really you really don't I mean to
go straight to the people you can go
straight to the people obviously being
independent I've been in an independent
artist with no major label backing I
have my own label right and I know what
it's like to sell CDs out of your trunk
I know what it's like to live in a
boarding house you know working at
Office Depot selling CDs out of your
trunk like I totally get that and it's
you know it's hard it's difficult for
Independent Artists but um I think if
you you know you you can rewrite the
rules as well
um I was gonna say for you like you are
also like a huge actress
you are in I mean you what was the uh
Glass Onion well I was saying the horror
movie like was it Antebellum oh yes
Antebellum yeah
um for you when you're in like acting
mode right because I know it's it's a
lot to to like act and like you have to
give your mental space to like being
someone else does it take away a lot
from the music like do you have to be in
like okay I'm turning down roles because
I'm working on music or can you do both
simultaneously
I think with music I have to be in the
studio and hands on with it I can't just
you know I need to be writing
collaborating living it you know
um touching it feeling it I Engineer a
lot of my sessions so even you're
running your own Pro Tools yeah well I
work out of logic oh oh yeah shout out
to live work out of logic yeah and I can
work out of Pro Tools but I prefer to do
logic um but yeah so just I need to be
super Hands-On with with music so I do
have to say no sometimes to you know
roles that may come in may come in and
sometimes that's difficult but music has
been so good to me a lot of the re you
know I think that I got a lot of my
movie roles because of my music career
because people were able to see me and
go into different characters with Glass
Onion the movie I just got finished
doing
um Ryan Johnson said that he was like I
saw that you could be you could embody
these different characters and this is
what we need in this movie you know it's
because of your film for dirty computer
and seeing you in your different music
videos and I was like oh she can do this
so um I'm gonna always make time for
music yeah